[Music]
so today we'll be talking about managing
applications the kubernetes way before
we get started with the session I would
like to do a little show of hands
exercise here how many of you are using
kubernetes at work or in your setup Wow
well how many of you how many of you are
using stateful workloads in kubernetes
great so this is actually a perfect
session for that then so so today we'll
be talking about how to extend
kubernetes to manage your workloads on
it so my name is Sunil Arora I'm a
software engineer at Google I've been
working with kubernetes for over two
years
I've contributed to projects like cube
control customized and most recently
I've been focusing on kubernetes
extensibility and I'm a tech lead and
maintainer for cube builder project and
with me we have June June P who is a
software engineer at Google working on
the kubernetes team so so the way we
have structured our talk today is first
we'll be going over some of the
kubernetes basics so the core patterns
that we use to write built-in api's and
controllers and then we'll be looking at
saw the ways to extend kubernetes
specifically focusing on API
extensibility and then we'll be diving
into cue builder the SDK which is how do
you build built-in API how do you build
api's and controllers and then the
favorite part of our section session
which is the demo and we'll be showing
you a sequel DB operator an example demo
here and we'll try to give 5 to 10
minutes at the end for the Q&A so with
that let's get started
I'll invite Jun to talk about what is
the kubernetes way hello everyone my
name is Joan I'm also a software
engineer at Google Cloud for the past
few years I work oka I
work on kubernetes controls and
operators and I'm eager today to share
we asked about the basics of communities
which we will cover in a transition
communities as you all know is a
container orchestration system the
automates deployment scaling and
management of containerized applications
it grows all the containers belonging to
an application into logical units for
each team management and discovery it
builds upon many years of Google's
experience in running production
workloads it is able to be run on major
public routes like TCP allow us easier
and with the latest technologies it is
also able to run on the on-prem crustose
it handles order the common cluster
routines like scheduling of noise
the lifecycle scaling etc on behalf of
users communities is an API centric
system what this means is that
everything communicates through the
api's the API server at the API server
is the center of universe in kubernetes
powers other api's it serves the rest
endpoints supporting other common crud
operations like creates gets updates
deletes it also stores the API resources
the objects in SCD almost all the
components in communities such as the
cryin like yukata the control plan
component like schedule and not adjourn
like queue bread have to talk through
the API server they had to send a
request to the server for processing now
let us have a real at the basic building
blocks or communities in cádiz we have
this concept named
pot a pot is basically a group of tiny
copper containers belonging to an
application and the sheriff volumes we
grab all the containers of an
application together and also the
necessary underlying volumes
between this pot and other containers
between the pots
share the same life cycle in fates so if
you have one pot if a part is down all
the containers between AIDS is also down
and the containers also share the same
IP and port space they see each other as
local house there are three types of
containers the any containers main
containers and cycle containers in the
containers perform initialization
routines like creating data directory
ordering the source codes before the
main container is stuttered the inner
container has to be completed before we
can start the main container main
container is where the real application
is running for example as an end user if
I deploy a radius application the
application will be run between the main
container and lastly the cycle container
is a container that provides additional
or routines and functions to assist the
main container
some examples are monitoring and logging
cycle one of the most important features
in community is dead it allows the end
users to specify the desired States the
tagger states the state's data one of
the Craster - kubernetes using
declarative api's this means that the
users only need to tell the unit is that
how many because the day one and
communities will basically do everything
perform the translation underneath
automatically this different from
imperative API in which the users have
to provide step-by-step instructions in
communities all the API resources all
the objects have an API that can be
broken down into three components the
first component is metadata in which you
can put the name namespace the labor's
etc and the second component is a spec
spec a PR field is where the
users provide the desired states and
that they won for this particular API
resource and lastly the status field is
where the communities are where updates
the current status the current states at
current point of time of the API
resource for example what is the number
of parts days already are ready at this
moment and how many of them is they're
not ready yet
now let us go to another important
concept in communities the controller a
controller is a long live control room
that performs the automatically
constellation on behalf of users the lea
constellation is made up of three steps
first it the controller or served the
assisting current states of the cluster
it then compares those states with
desired states that the crust are the
decal states provided by the users it
reduce the differences and then it acts
upon the differences by bringing the
cluster to the desired States for an
example let's say we have a cluster and
the cluster runs to application
instances however the user specified
that there is a need to have three
number array because running at any
given time so what happens here is that
the controller will create an honorific
house to measure that the total number
only because is always three similar
thing happens unless say initially we
have four we because the controller will
then delete one of the Astra gripper
cars and now let us go over some
primitives in communities primitives or
the built-in controls or communities is
widely used for running the applications
I believe most of you have already used
them
I will go to some of them the first one
is typical sets because that is a
controller that's maintained a set apart
of identical parts at any given point of
time a grant is a variability of a
certain number of parts if a point star
it will always restart its the next
control is deployment deployment is a
little bit communicated but it is a
higher level controller deaths provides
because if updates for the river
cassettes and parts what happens this
when a user created the primary source a
correspondingly because said our
resource will also be created by the
deployment controller and then the
lubricants a controller that are we
mentioned just now we are create a part
hence the deployment controller will
manage other parts in delivery through
the river cassette controller and lastly
it is the staff user controller our
stepheson controller is used
specifically for managing the staff for
applications when we mention about the
step for applications we refer to those
applications there are depends on the
data States for our random operations
accurately yeah all the parts between
the staff who said maintain a sticky
identity that has a persistent
identifier that will be remained the
same throughout any list scheduling of
the pot for the first part of a step set
we have the index number 0 and for the
second one we have one and so on for the
next session our suniye would guide us
through the standing kubernetes
let's look at how kubernetes have
evolved with respect to running
applications so initially it started
with stateless apps which are very
simple apps and if you look at the
operations involved in managing the
lifecycle of state stateless apses on
day 0 you would just orchestrate them
and day 2 would pretty much require
either scaling them up or down or would
require updating which is a rollout so
those operations are supported by the
existing primitives like replicas and in
deployment you can just use those and
they are good enough to run straight
less workloads now moving on to simples
stateful apps those are these are apps
which are not distributed they are kind
of very simple to run so for that
stateful set and CSI gives you good
enough primitive to run them
successfully for de 0 and T and
operations now let's look at a complex
app which is think of a distributed
application like a datastore or let's
say a messaging application like Kafka
so on day 0 it involves orchestration
which is setting up the initial topology
they - typically that's where the real
trouble starts which is let's say you
want to take backup or you want to
restore depending on the application
application may have its own storage
semantics for that now update might
involve like these applications have
their own clustering mechanisms so
update might require lot of coordination
between the nodes similarly when it
comes to scaling them which is you want
to adjust the topology so that would
also require coordination between the
nodes nodes it gets really complicated
and so it goes on you want to
reconfigure the same thing so if you
have such an application now this is
beyond kubernetes knowledge to provide
primitives to operate these independent
applications so what would have been
really nice if you could model all these
operations of these complex applications
as declarative API is and you can use
the same tooling like cube control to
operate on them and so for example here
it would be nice if I were to launch a
DB instance I could just set here is
expect from my DB instance which is read
replicas as two storages I want this
sort of storage
I want backup to be done weekly I want
backup storage to be used using slow
disk and things like those and I can
perform all those I can manage all those
operations using the cube can't you
control API
dueling so but so kubernetes doesn't
give you those primitives but it it
provides these extension mechanisms
which can which you can use to build
such an experience on top of kubernetes
so let's look at when kubernetes was
started it was started with the goal of
being just a container orchestration
system but over the years what I've been
seeing last two years team and community
has put in so much effort in making the
system extensible and now it has evolved
into a platform so it provides
constructs which you can build on top of
so because when it comes to running
application it is just not running
application within Kuban it is it is a
lot of stuff which is around application
which people have to worry about it is
policy enforcement it's about continuous
deployment so I think with evolving it
as a platform I think there's a lot of
pieces that community has contributed if
you look at that is making the whole
platform really powerful as well
so there are two dimensions to extending
kubernetes one is infrastructure
extensibility which is extending it to
different hardware providers different
storage providers the second is API
extensibility and which is what we'll be
focusing on today so in the next few
slides I will be covering the two main
important API extensibility mechanisms
and then we'll go back and reconnect
with that slide we talked about earlier
how to manage the complex application so
the first primitive is custom resource
and you must have heard of this term CID
everywhere so custom resource is nothing
but is another API provided by
kubernetes which allows you to introduce
your own API in the cluster and to give
you an example so custom resource
definition how do you do that so custom
resource definition is another a
declarative yeah mph file you specify
the sort of what I would call schema for
your custom resource think of it as
let's say if you have data base sequel
database you would define when you
create a table you define a schema
then you have rows in the table in the
similar way CID is the definition is the
schema for your API and custom resource
instance are think of them as the actual
instances for that resource so the way
so let's say once you have the CML file
which defines the schema for say custom
resource where you can specify the API
group the version and the kind and then
there are additional features that CRD
supports for example open API validation
you can specify what fields what sort of
validation needs to be performed then
printer column support which I'll cover
later when I do a live demo so the way
to think about this is once you submit
the CML file then kubernetes api server
gives you this host its endpoint service
it will automatically create a rest
endpoint for that api resource and now
this api is available to all the
existing tooling and clients in order to
consume so the experience is very
similar to what you will have for
building api's so the second primitive
extension point that kubernetes provides
is the admission revokes so if you look
at the life cycle of a request in the
kubernetes api server let's say an
incoming resource like pod when it hits
the API server it will go through the
series of admission control plug-ins
there's some built-in admission control
plugins but there are two additional new
ones which got introduced in last year
or so is validating their book and
mutating their book so let's look at one
by one so validating web book is where
kubernetes api server for each incoming
resource can make a request to an
external HTTP web service and that
service can say whether to accept or
reject this incoming resource now this
can be used to implement some very
powerful mechanisms like let's say you
want to enforce certain policies in your
system which is a simple example would
be you want to allow only certain images
to be running in kubernetes so this
would be one way to do it
let's look at another extension
bond which is mutating webhook which is
so let's say you have an incoming
resource like bard and if you kubernetes
api server will call another HTTP api
service which can mutate the in spec of
the incoming resole so in this case
let's say you can modify the part and
then it will be persisted in that CD
after going through so now modification
this enables some of the really powerful
use cases one would be let's say there
are things that you want to do across
your applications one would be let's say
you want to inject the citecar container
for log collection so you can do such a
thing using mutating webhook or let's
say for some other let's say sto is one
where they use sidecar injection for the
NY proxy and things like those so
another thing we're mutating rare-book
is used which is for defaulting so if
you have an API and user has not
specified certain fields and you want to
put in some sensible defaults that would
be another use case for mutating member
so so we covered CR D and we covered
admission webhook and now let's go back
and reconnect the dot with how do you
manage a complex application which has
which is very which has like date
managing de to operations are very
unique to that application so you take
these three building blocks first is use
the CR D to introduce the declarative
API so then you take all that
operational knowledge of your
application which might be sitting
either in play books or some bunch of
bash script or maybe sometimes in wiki
pages so you can take that operational
knowledge put that in the controllers
and with that you will have a working
API to manage your application and now
optionally you can use admission
WebWorks now in it when it comes to
orchestrating and managing all the
workflows related to application you can
leverage all the kubernetes primitives
you can for service discovery you can
use the services
you can use pod stateful set or replica
set for orchestrating or what I call as
infrastructure programming for you can
use secrets and config map for configs
and credential management so you don't
have to reinvent the wheel over there
and if you look at some of the built-in
controllers are also then like that
where replica set is built on top of
pods and deployment is built on top of
replicas set so there's a hierarchy of
resources there so and once you have
that you use the existing tools like
cube control to manage the application
so to the end-users they this it's built
in API pretty much for them and that's
the whole idea and you get all the other
features like authorization
authentication and auditing that comes
with the API for free so with that so
now we know that okay these are the
primitives available and these are you
can build your custom controllers
application controllers to manage your
application now let's look at how we can
do that so in this section we'll be
talking about queue builder so queue
builder is an open source project under
kubernetes org it's actually a sub
project of special interest group API
machinery so the project was started
about a year back and we looked at the
state of the art for writing custom
custom controller at that point and it
was very complex so you have you need to
have deep understanding of low-level
kubernetes api x' to write something
workable and it required lot of copying
pasting of code which was very
error-prone and the documentation also
was very fragmented in all over the
place so we looked at that problem and
we said how can we solve it how we can
make it really easy to extend kubernetes
how we can take all those extension
point and let people bring their
expertise of writing managing the
application and pair it together with
the extension points and
make it easy to extend kubernetes so
let's look at some of the components of
queue builder project so the three main
components on top you have this queue
builder CLI which is which bootstraps
our user project and it will the
day-to-day flow of either bootstrapping
or adding new api's and controllers or
updating the dependencies in the
projects are stunned by the queue
builder project and then there are two
components controller tools and
controller runtime which are used by the
user project itself to implement the
api's and controllers so let's look at
the tools what do they do so the first
is when you want to let's say you
decided to write an API and controller
you would start with an empty directory
and you would like to bootstrap the
project so the first set of set of
commands which sets of the dependencies
sets up the right directory structure
looking at some of the things that we
have learned over the past years by
looking writing custom controllers so we
have baked those all in these tools so
what would be what would the maker
docker file look like and we'll scaffold
the make file which would pretty much
have most common targets that you would
use in day-to-day development of your
controller then when it comes to adding
api's and controllers scaffoldings or
the boilerplate code automatically for
you
wiring them up with the right set of
underlying clients and libraries so this
is the part which cube builder does and
then the controller tools is so like we
discussed about see IDs are the way to
introduce your API so it has tools to
generate the C IDs so the tools
basically look at the types dot go and
we'll show you in the demo how that is
done and then see ID generation of the
CR DS then the last part is which is
when let's say you have your controller
ready you want the you want the
manifests that you need for deploying in
Kuban it is so you have tools for
generating those as well
and then this is the most important
component of queue builder which is the
controller runtime like I discussed
before the state of the art was copying
and pasting the code so we looked at
some of the common patterns that you
have to do when you're writing
controllers for example you want to
observe certain resources in in
kubernetes then you want to invoke
reconciliation you want to run this
active reconciliation loops you want to
run a number of threads over there and
so all those some of the things that a
common patterns we abstracted them out
and provided some intuitive API is to
use that so that users don't have to
worry about this low-level underneath it
uses the low-level kubernetes
upstream climb client libraries but you
get the more intuitive patterns that you
can directly apply then another is very
similarly we extended it to admission
and conversion web hooks which the API
is and then the third part which we have
seen that is one of which is you it's
about the providing a dynamic kubernetes
client which can work with any
kubernetes resource so that also makes
things really easier to understand
because now you have a very less API
surface area when it comes to client
which can talk to any resource so
essentially the whole idea is that we
are still iterating over this these
libraries and as we are learning more
and more about the best practices we're
trying to make them in either in the
core library or as in utility functions
that people can use and so another
example is like when you are running
your controller in the production you
want to be you want access to all the
metrics to debug any production
scenarios so the controller runtime
library automatically provides all the
metrics like the reconciliation errors
the number of reconciliation what is the
backlog queue that you have in the
reconciliation so things like those are
automatically supported so I think with
that can we switch to the terminal we
would so we would look at some of the
cube builder flow and I will also show
you controller tools and controller
runtime abstract so let's so right now
we are in an in a directory which we
have already bought strat for our
project
the sequel DB operator and so let's say
you have downloaded Cube builder release
on your laptop and after that what you
will get is cube builder CLI on your
command from so you can basically there
not much commands actually if you look
at so the first thing that you want to
do is you want to invoke you want to
bootstrap your project so the way to do
it would be I have already done it so
I'm just going to show the command here
so you just run cube builder in it which
will initialize your project it takes
bunch of parameters like you can specify
the license that you want to include
what are the owners you want to use in
the copy editor fie copy header that
shows up at the top of the file then
once you have that what you what you'll
see is it will scaffold the project
structure for you so this is pretty much
the structure that every kubernetes
project that will see follows and so
let's look at very quickly some of the
things that it did for us so it sets up
the go dependencies you see the go
package lock and go package normal file
which is we're using go depth for
managing dependencies so we set that up
automatically so that all the kubernetes
dependencies gets pulled for you so that
gets pulled in the vendor directory here
then look at we automatically create
docker file scaffold the docker file
which we will which will use for
building the controller image that we
can run it in cluster then we scaffold
the make file I can quickly show you the
make file so make file s of the common
targets that you'll be invoking so one
example would be you'll be scoping and
let's say you want to run test you want
to build the manager binary you want to
run
you want to install CR T's in this is in
the cluster you want to deploy the
manifest you want to let's say clean up
all the manifests that you deployed so
all these common workflow it
automatically is available right off the
bat when you run that command then let's
show you a little bit of the code so so
this is will scaffold the main dot go
which is the entry point for your
controller where it will read the config
which is the kubernetes conflict whether
you are running on locally or in the
cluster it will automatically set that
for you create the controller manager
which is basically a shell you can think
which is going to host all these
controllers a set of controllers because
when you are writing API you will be you
can have multiple set of controllers to
power the same API performing different
functionalities so then in the end you
just invoke manager start here so let's
go back now let's look at so up till now
let's say this is the bootstrapping of
the project then the next step would be
you want to add an API and API step
would be you just run this command let's
say like in this case we wanted to add
an API called sequel DB we wanted to add
viven alpha 1 and at this group so we
invoke you builder create API and now it
will create scaffold scaffold out the
API and the controller files so let's
very quickly go over those so package is
where API is and controller code lives
so in the API is you have in front of
you an alpha one so let's look at one of
the one of the files so this is your
types dot go for the kubernetes api now
it will start with so this is our first
API let's a sequel DB like June
explained earlier every kubernetes api
have this these fields like it will have
the type meta information the object
meta information which is basically the
metadata and type meta and then the spec
and then the status so spec is where it
is all application dependent Eve what
are the what are the fields you want to
do
as input from users so like in this case
the database type the version of the
database that you want to run and then
you can have different fields for the
topology you want to set up like the
replicas and like the discs you want to
use things like those so while we are
here I wanted to show we talked about
how Cube controller tools is some one of
the tools that takes your types dot go
and it generates CRD schema so you will
see that these are queue builder
directives that you can specify in the
code hairs like here I'm using a feature
of C I D which is print column feature
which lets you decide what columns you
want to print by default when a user
performs Cube control get on that
resource like for pods you see certain
columns for for your own resource you
want to show you want to customize the
output so this is where you configure
the feature for cid and controller tools
is going to take this as input and
generate the cid EML files for example i
can quickly show the config for this api
the cid so see add this the cre
definition for sequel DB API that we
added is so this is generated for
example the name of the CR DS here like
the printer column spec that I showed
you earlier this got generated in the
form of here so it's saying that okay
show replica is one of the columns and
get this is the JSON path for extracting
that value that you want to show so
there are other features like similarly
if you want to add more validation you
can enter you can annotate the fields in
your types rot go with the open api s--
specific annotations and the controller
tools are going to generate the scheme
automatically for you
so this where your code is in sync with
the cid schema so yeah that was quick
about the cre schema and then we can
look at just very briefly at the
controller
as well your controller code is like in
this demo we have two controllers so
sequel DB and sequel back up so secretly
B controller here is where so you'll see
the controller runtime the library part
that I talked about earlier so this is
what is we are importing that and we are
using so the first thing controller
wants to do is being able to watch
observe the resources so you will see
that this requires just a simple so we
have these high level API is where you
can say how to watch this resource of
kind this or in this case the three
objects that we care about is the sequel
DB and sequel DB basically uses stateful
set and services for orchestrating the
sequel DB so we have watching those
resources as well and then some things
where you can specify can set up the
ownership hierarchy which is so with
just few lines of code here it will
automatically set up okay it will
trigger write objects that gets queued
in the reconciliation for reconciliation
now let's look at quickly how
reconciliation code looks like
so typically all you need to do is if
you add your watches correctly then you
can just focus on the reconcile function
and here this can get this the code this
this will actually depend on the
complexity of the application you're
managing like in this case you'll first
get whatever resource you need to
reconcile you want to probably default
if this resource was not created one set
of the defaults you can do validation
also here then
so yeah this code will I will not
actually go through and this code in
detail so let's skip this this is where
controller and API code is organized so
I think now this would be the right time
to switch to the next part where let's
look at the sequel DB operator so June
would be over view how the sequel DB
operator that we wrote for this demo is
set up so
thanks to Neil for the odd literal
explanation about cuter in this session
we will show how computer is used to
create a simple operator a simple step
operator named sicko DB before diving
deep into the demo I wish to provide a
high-level overview of what operator
does the operator creates a managed
progress cluster a comprised of two abs
nice jr. state is a secret EB API and
the seeker Baker ap is the secret EB API
is used for a creation and restore of
the Postgres clusters without the back
the secret Baker API is used for backup
the data of the crustal underlying all
the Postgres cluster created by the
operator we have a shared storage layer
underneath we use a network file system
to store a backup file and then retrieve
the backup file for the restoration
purpose we run the operator between
algae critique raster and create the
manifest
to create those 0 DB and a Sukkah Becker
resources our demo flow is very simple a
comprised of only three steps the first
step is to create a secretive resource
to roll out a crust and waits for the
Postgres cluster to become ready and
then we populate the data to its
personal debts for simplicity reasons in
our demo we will only start one
Postgres database instance so a cluster
means only one instance of a database
and in a second session we will create a
secret Baker resource to trigger the
backup of a data that we insert that
into the cluster in step one and lastly
we'll create another secretive resource
to roll out another cluster and we will
verify that the data of the old Craster
can be restored to a second cluster
yeah um now let us go over the workflows
for the Postgres database instant
creation what happens here is that the
users create a single dippity sauce
ah when the controller of Sirte creation
event the control creates a state
facility sauce with inspect of the
stepheson resource we specify the
Postgres as the container image and then
the staff was a controller one of the
primitives that we went over in session
one creates the pot and between the pot
there is the main container running the
Postgres database and we use a post-grad
specific client named psql to assess the
container this is done through a scuba
Nadi's service resource this service is
a lot parents or service that has posed
the container to the crier and all of
this information is hidden from the
end-users all the end-users had to do is
very simple just by running the Kolkata
app right the manifest file other users
had to do is to create the secret
abusers and that's it from the back of
row what the users can do with the
operator is that he or she can create a
secret becca resource the Pekka resource
has the reference back to the secret
ability we created in a previous
workflow and with this information the
secret becca controller is able to
identify which container that it's once
to run a command with the controller
will run a command within a container to
trigger the Bekaa utility to perform the
backup what happens here is that a
backup will be created a utility and
stop into the underlying network file
system Chris no debts for the name of
our system we can substitute it for
other storage mediums such as the Google
Cloud storage and the Amazon s3 and
agile storage is possible it is
interchangeable and lastly for the
restore waterflow the users are
create a secondary resource by this time
this deep resource has one additional
API fear
that reference back to the seeker Becca
resource why we want to do this this
because we want to get a backup file
information from the Becca resource
using the Becca file name the secret EP
controller is able to fetch the correct
Becca fowl from the underlying network
file system and then are called restore
utility to perform the restoration in
the end a new crust will be created and
the trustor will be loaded with a backup
data and Suniya will show us all the
referrals through a demo ok so I'm going
to so with this let's look at what we
have so right now I have a gk cluster
and let me quickly check if we have
connectivity here so yeah we have a 5
node cluster here and we already have
deployed the controller in the cluster
so let's look at the CR DS the first
step would be let's look at the CR DS
installed in the system so we have
already created to see our DS which is
sequel TVs and sequel DB backup we can
quickly look at one of the CR DS here so
yeah you'll you'll see whatever in the
earlier part I showed the CR definition
that's where we see pretty much very
similar to that here so now the next
step that you want to do is I'm going to
show the conflict that we generated for
let's look at the user wants to create a
DB instance so this is this this is the
conflict that looks like for the DB
instance where you specify the name you
specify what version of the database you
want to use what type of database you
want to use in this case we're using
Postgres and then the disk information
for like what this to use in also we can
do
okay before I dive into that so on on
the right hand side what I have is think
of this as another application which is
running in the cluster which is going to
access the database which is provisioned
by when we submit the resource dv1
resource so I'm going to apply DB one
and so you say that database request is
accepted we can examine the sequel DB s
by running cube control get here so this
is the part I was explaining earlier
where these are the columns that you can
configure so since it's a yeah so this
become became ready very pretty fast so
let's look at we can access this on this
service endpoint so status is one where
yet is using the status field here so we
are using hard coding the credentials
here so we'll use that okay so we are in
so you can see that what we did is we
submitted the DB one yeah Mel file using
cube control not using any new sort of
tools to work with our database and then
we use the existing primitives like
services to expose it and if you look at
it is it is using stateful sets so you
can exempt not here if you look at it it
created a DB one straight full set which
is actually running the Postgres pod and
container inside it so now let's look at
we want to take a backup which is what
the day to operation looks like so for
backup if you want to do is let's say
this is also modeled as another API
sequel backup and in this case it's a
very simple API we are saying you're
just back up the DB one and you want to
save the output in this file now we can
just apply this the similar way so this
is like a day to operation you can
imagine which is taking a backup
okay so the backup is succeeded so yeah
I mean depending on the application you
can output whatever things you want to
output here so now the third step is
which is we want to restore which is
another day and operation that you want
to perform so restauration workflow so
what you want to do is we'll be using
db2 here we were to bring either another
instance we want to restore from the
backup that we took earlier and we'll
just use the backup name DV 1 backup
here so we just apply this and so yeah
so with that we see db2 is also ready
and maybe here additional things could
be done is that this was restored from
this TB or additional data that can be
shown here now ok we did not create any
entry in the previous before taking
backup so yeah the idea was actually
we'll create some data and then we'll
take the backup and then will restore it
we can still do that I think we have
time so let's create some entries here
okay so I'm still connected to the DV 1
if you look at the DV 1 has this delayed
30 p2 and then try D again yeah you can
actually delete so that is another thing
which so we deleted the db2 and we want
to take backup as well so let's delete
backup as well
okay so now we want to take the back up
let's do that oh sorry you can pick up
teachers so yeah back up is succeeded so
now we create the db2 here so we're just
repeating the same thing here and this
should restore from the backup that we
took earlier we can look at
okay so db2 is also ready so now what we
can do is let's connect to db2 June is
not feeling confident but let's see yeah
we have that row so yeah it's it's
working
[Applause]
yeah as you can see the status of a db2
had chant of celery stock oh okay okay
yeah so with that you looked at the day
zero and day and operation what it
looked like for an example so this is
not a production ready sequel TV
operator so please don't use that and so
so I think with this it's pretty much
the end of our session so can we switch
back to the slide and I want to go over
the takeaways real quick yes of the
takeaways that I would like to mention
over here is the first is that
kubernetes offers really powerful API
extension mechanisms and if you look at
some of the product launches that have
happened at GCP like in the
pastor now sto or cloud Nate K native
all these are built on top of those
extension points
so that's the first takeaway the second
one is you can manage complex
application using operator pattern the
one that we showed earlier by extending
kubernetes that's a key takeaway and the
third is the cube builder SDK which
provides you all the tools at the
libraries to extend Kuban it is so yeah
with that I would leave you with this
slide where we have all the link all the
links to the resources that we saw today
this the operator code the cube builder
book the also this so cube builder has
an active slack channel so I've also put
in the link for that if if you have any
queries you can jump on the slack
channel and ask about it and the code
that we showed today is also open
sourced under Google cloud platform
Kate's equal DB operator so go through
that and then we have mine and June's
github handle and Twitter handle as well
so feel free to reach out
[Music]